this is a complex search effort which
requires multiple agencies with subject
matter expertise and specialized
equipment
while the U.S Coast Guard has assumed
the role of search and rescue mission
coordinator we do not have all of the
necessary expertise and Equipment
retired required in the search of this
nature the unified command brings that
expertise and additional capability
together to maximize effort in solving
this very complex problem
and we're out of voter here
as a recap on Sunday
the uh
the coordination Command Center in
Boston received a report from the
Canadian Expedition vessel a polar
prints of an overdue 21 foot submarine
Titan with five people on board
the Titan was attempting to dive on the
wreck of the Titanic approximately 900
miles east of Cape Cod and 400 miles
south of St John's Newfoundland
approximately one hour and 45 minutes
into the scheduled dive the polar prints
lost all communication with the Titan
the polar prints conducted an initial
search and then requested Coast Guard
assistance
the U.S Coast Guard in Boston assumed
the responsibility of search and rescue
mission coordinator and immediately
launched search assets
since Sunday the Coast Guard has
coordinated search efforts
where the U.S and Canadian Coast Guard
Air National Guard aircraft and the
polar prints which is searched to
combine 7 600 square miles an area
larger than the state of Connecticut
these search efforts have focused on
both surface with C-130 aircraft
searching by sight and with radar and
subsurface with P3 aircraft
were able to drop and monitor sonar
buoys to date those search efforts have
not yielded any results
search efforts have continued through
last night and today
The Vessel deep energy 194 meter
pipeling vessel arrived on scene with
underwater ROV capability
they have rendezvous with the vessel
polar prints and commenced an ROV dive
at the last known of the position of the
Titan in the approximate position of the
Titanic wreck that operation is
currently ongoing
additionally a Canadian P3 aircraft is
currently conducting a six-hour search
of the area and several C-130 aircraft
and another P3 are scheduled to fly this
afternoon and this evening
the Canadian Coast Guard Cutter or
vessel John Cabot is scheduled to arrive
later this evening
and several other Canadian Coast Guard
vessels and the Coast Guard Cutter
Sycamore are in route
Additionally the U.S Coast Guard has
the U.S Navy's sub-soul
supervisor of salvaging diving command
is working with U.S Transportation
command to bring additional assets to
the search area
these are more capable assets will be
staged out of St John's for further
transport search area
there are also several private vessels
research vessels ROV capabilities that
are making preparations to join the
efforts
so I want to reiterate this is a very
complex search and the unified team is
working around the clock to bring all
available assets and expertise to bear
as quickly as possible in an effort to
solve this very complex problem we'll
continue to provide updates as they
become available
and again our thoughts and prayers are
with the crew and the families and their
loved ones
we will provide unwavering effort as we
continue the search and I think at this
time we'll open it up and take a few
questions
[Music]
so so each of the rovs uh so that's kind
of a vague question right there rov's
have different capability it's our
understanding the current ROV that is
deployed at the site now has some
limited capability uh it has a camera on
board
um but but again each of those is
different and uh we'll be gathering more
information as that operation uh goes on
for the day Captain it's Tom Costello
with NBC News uh if your submersibles
can find this sub is there any way to
retrieve it and save the people on board
yeah so right now all of our efforts are
focused on finding the sub what I will
tell you is we have a group of of uh our
nation's best experts in the unified
command and if we get to that point uh
those experts will be looking at what
the next course of action is
that you know of or that you can
estimate right now on the submersible
and is it a pass does it have to be
approved or regulated sure so
so first of all that's an estimate right
because we know uh from the
the data we were using as a starting
point was 96 hours we know at this point
we're approximately uh about 40 41 hours
to go through anything
yeah I'm not sure of the exact technical
uh pieces that we know there's about uh
there's about 40 hours of breathable air
uh left based on that initial report
again uh that was just the initial
report based on 96 hours uh from when
the vessel um
or so if you were to find the
submersible at this moment would that
give you enough time to save these five
people on board yeah I suppose I don't
know the answer to that question what I
will tell you is we will do everything
in our power to uh to affect a rescue um
again
it's going to depend on if the ROV finds
something it's going to depend on what
they find what what needs to be uh what
steps need to be taken next and uh and
really that is for the experts within
the unified command
um to take a look at and then and then
decide what the best course of action is
not eight hours
because right now uh our effort and our
focus is on searching with what we know
uh when as soon as we receive the report
on Sunday evening we immediately
launched search efforts we flew assets
that evening and we've continued
constant surface and air asset searches
uh since that point
well
it's a this is a complex search and it's
complex for a variety of reasons
um
we're you know you're talking about a
search area that's 900 miles east of
Cape Cod 400 miles south of St John's So
logistically speaking it's hard to bring
assets to Bear it takes time it takes
coordination
um
and then we're dealing with uh you know
two pieces of you're dealing with a
surface search and a subsurface search
and frankly that makes it an incredibly
complex operation
well the U.S Navy or the Canadian Navy
be able to get Salvage equipment on time
before the air runs out obviously uh
getting Salvage equipment on scene is a
top priority uh unified command is
working through that to prioritize uh
what equipment we can get there there
are ongoing operations right now via the
U.S Navy and transcom to get to get
equipment uh staged in St John's and get
it on scene I can't give you an exact
timeline of when that's going to happen
but what I can tell you is there is a
full press full court press effort to
get equipment on scene as quickly as we
can
so some of the equipment that's coming
is coming from the East Coast but again
we're talking about very heavy equipment
it's a complicated transport operation
but the best Professionals in the world
are working it and that's uh us transcom
yeah so like I said there are some there
are several civilian ships uh that have
offered Services heading that way there
are additional Coast Guard Putters we
hope to have a Canadian Coast Guard
Cutter on scene this evening we hope
that they may be able to assume on scene
Commander uh polar Prince has been doing
a great job with those duties but if we
take some of that from them uh that
would be good but your your question
about specific equipment I I'm not going
to get into talking about specific
equipment frankly I'm not an expert on
what that equipment is but again I can
tell you we have experts in the unified
command that are going through that
prioritizing what we need and then how
we get it on scene
both the personal from Boston uh how
many people from here are out there
from Boston specifically so the so
Boston where Boston plays role is the
the command center the rescue and
coordination Center is here in Boston
um the the aircraft that are coming in
are coming from different locations um
but uh but the command uh structure is
being worked out of uh out of Boston and
I think we have time for for two more
questions
well I yeah I don't want to speak about
it the Coast Guard is ever I would tell
you it's a unique operation it's a
challenging operation
um but uh but right now we're focused on
on putting everything we can at it and
uh and searching
um as hard as we can and getting assets
out there
um as quickly as we can
the other assets
[Music]
yeah so there are some additional assets
with rovs
um there is uh one asset they make that
is working to get on scene with a
decompression chamber
um so those are all pieces that are
coming together and uh and we're working
those logistical challenges to get them
uh get them there and I think we'll take
one more
well I can't tell you exactly what it
would look like I would tell you that uh
you know
we are out there we're searching we
wouldn't be doing this we wouldn't be
searching and putting all effort out
there
um I think that you know
if the sub is located that's a question
that then the the experts need to look
at what is the best course of action uh
for recovering this up but I think it's
going to depend on that particular
situation and uh and if we encounter
that sure is it true that the British
off assistance and they were told we
don't need your assistance at this point
no I'm not aware of that again what I
would tell you though is that the
unified command is working through uh
working through prioritizing and we know
that there's equipment out there that
can be brought to the scene
um
the unified commands working through
prioritizing what equipment we need and
then how we get it there so since you're
also responding the ship as well yes
that's my understanding correct and uh
thank you thank you thank God I really
appreciate you guys coming out today
through this portion of the brief on
there um I can stay behind just to take
some additional stuff that maybe wasn't
answered we can try to get some
information back to you kind of a little
bit later
[Music]
right so the uh the rescue coordination
Center that he's talking about
specifically that's based in Boston so
the Personnel that are working in the
command and control environment as far
as uh uh building a lot of the search
and rescue plans sending out the
information coordinating those pieces
are here the uh the people affecting the
mission so the pilots the air Crews uh
all the ships those are based out of
different areas so our Pilots air crews
are out of Elizabeth City North Carolina
the Coast Guard Cutter Sycamore I
believe is out of Newport Rhode Island
but they were operating already in the
Arctic so
there are a number of people that are
here working in a staff element but are
not
physically located out in the search
area
it is yes
[Music]
I don't know it sounds like for the most
part the staging area is moving to St
John's
so yeah I believe yeah a lot of it into
St John uh Newfoundland right yeah
that's so our uh aircraft the C-130
aircraft are they're based out of there
as well so I know there is a number of
uh pieces going out there logistically
it's easier as opposed to from here
um so I know a lot of those questions
weren't were unanswered on there and
it's a lot of us because we're not the
right agency to be asking that I know
it's a big fan we should be uh to be
able to give the answer to you but we
want you guys to hear from the Civil
Defender experts uh so that's our next
plan is what we want to do is give an
opportunity for you all to have to get
all of the subject better experts we can
into one location to kind of get those
questions answered
um
to give you kind of the best thing we
can do I think yeah anticipated that was
40 hours when that becomes a recovery
Mission if you're choose
I'm sorry when those 40 hours yesterday
is that the moment you ship from a
search and rescue to a recovery
operation if you choose to do it
I think it really depends on a number of
factors so anything that could change
between now and then as far as uh
information response you know things
like that that could change that so it's
not a hard and fast
um you know timer's up time to
transition there's a lot of factors that
go into it that could extend uh
something like that
play in one of those factors in with 40
hours of office again left when would
you then transition from a search recipe
I don't know I don't know an answer to
that that's that's definitely outside we
can try to get back to as we transition
through that phrase we'll have better
answers for that information
[Music]
so the weather was yep so actually I
have
um I believe the weather on scene today
uh was a five to six foot Seas
um
so wave height five to six feet
um I believe it was 15 knot winds
visibility was was very foggy yesterday
with very little nose visibility uh but
was was
um increasing today and they were
expecting better in much better
conditions uh from an aerial search
perspective
I was 15 nutmans
so in terms it's it's um
it's not it's about average out there
right how long would it take a typical
Coast Guard vessel from the U.S or for
that matter from Newfoundland to get on
site if they're running at maximum speed
that depends on the cutter itself or the
ship itself because they all have
different speeds yeah
um but you have an average just we have
a feel for how long it would take to get
there well depending on where they're
coming from uh it could be a matter of
you know
two days up to four to five days it just
depends on where they would be deploying
from so from Newfoundland for example
um
I don't know we don't have any ships up
in there so I don't know I don't have an
answer to that Canadian we're trying to
find out more information on the
Canadian vessels that are assisting on
their sort of what their capabilities
speeds are I still have an answer for
you on that right now
going down for the Titanic the Coast
Guard specifically no this this type of
the salad operation in our expertise as
an organization is you know in terms of
private companies so that's all part of
the conversations even by the band to to
find out what capabilities are out there
and explore all avenues
[Music]
haven't received any yet at this point
we do we do expect to get some um like
you said we do have uh some graphics
that we're trying to look to send out
this afternoon
um
as well as we've reached out to the
aircraft Crews to get uh footage from
them now I know what the the rovs that
are on scene today so there hasn't been
any before so we've our our requesting
out there to try and see what we can get
to go through that and try to make that
available to you all
[Music]
is
called Coast Guard assets itself now we
do not have any Coast Guard cutters
no so the research passes I just don't
know what the capabilities are pretty
unrealistic
but they've done all of these aerial
searches
that's why we have both types of assets
because we don't want to exhaust one
possibility in Vice of another so we
don't want to rule out what bet it is on
the surface and the way that our crews
train this is the environment they train
and they're specialized in being able to
see these things from the air so they've
given everything that they have to it
and if it's on the surface we're fairly
certain that we would be able to find it
know that we that we will find it if it
is
possible to say can I just ask you to I
realize this may be challenging you may
not have the answer but we're trying to
get a sense of how far away the nearest
Naval asset would be that has that lift
capability Salvage capability is it
coming from North Carolina from Florida
from Boston any can you give us any idea
of how far away it might be I don't
have an answer to that yeah do you know
if anybody uh
research vessel
oh communicating with them no I don't
have specifics on technology on board
you understanding the past on other
expeditions has there ever been involved
that's my knowledge is cooperated with
the investigation absolutely they're so
yeah they're part of the unified command
in here so we're all making decisions
together so did they
I don't know
um but
if they do it's definitely being
discussed as far as their capabilities
and that's just the biggest part of the
challenge of all of us is trying to
understand how
the capabilities are working together
how they would do it the technical
aspect of that so if you're a family
member
I think it was it was clearly saying
could you could we ask you could you
just describe if you know the crush
depth here we're talking about 400 times
as I understand it what we all
experience at sea level
what can that do to a vessel
I can't I can't speak to the scientific
side of that
um again this is just more or less
trying to get some background
information for you guys on there I
don't have any of that information on
that can you tell us about what the um
and that would be a great question that
we could try to get asked for you with
that subject matter expert
discussion that we talked about for the
it's a good opportunity for you guys to
ask that question because
it'd be much more important and
realistic for somebody within that
Community uh part of the command that
would be able to answer that question a
lot clearer than anything I could I
would be able to so yeah when might you
provide your next
couple uh so we do have a press release
that's going to be going out shortly
with the graphics we talked about
um
probably similar information to what was
passed today
um
if any new information comes up we'll
update that but I think ideally we'll be
putting out press releases daily and um
would look at probably doing another
briefing tomorrow can I just ask you one
last all right let's roll I don't know
could you just reiterate for us and just
how big of an urgency is this for the
Coast Guard how big of a priority do you
prioritize these things in other words
do you classify them as
priority red one two three how big of a
priority is this this operation is our
top priority right now
um you know within the district we have
uh you know every available asset that
we can uh that's to this that we can
dedicate to it on this
[Music]
um
that's not why we are are spending so
much time and energy trying to
coordinate uh really this enormous
response effort um to truly understand
the scale of how far away this truly is
um and in the context of
the types of assets that we can get out
there over something that's that
enormous something larger than the state
of Connecticut
into perspective of what is available to
be able to search in those kind of
conditions so far offshore
understanding 900 miles looks like
um is an enormous amount of distance
I don't know I don't know I don't know
what it would look like
um realistic and that's that's all part
of the conversation in fact man that
we're looking at doing everything that
they can to find out the options that
are available
[Music]
so the not until all the next two
notifications have been completed
um through that process can we release
things in that way I know that some have
gotten out but they have not been
through us okay
thank you I really appreciate it thank
you and uh we'll send out an update when
the next uh advisory or
um uh uh advisory would be out for you
guys
not that I'm aware of that nothing that
we are setting up now I don't know if
they are up there independent well there
we are that is the end of the news
conference in Boston uh on the issue of
this missing uh submersible uh and uh
well the important news came a little
bit earlier from Captain Jamie Frederick
of the U.S Coast Guard who said his
thoughts and prayers were with the five
crew members and their families but he
said a complex search is underway
involving multiple agencies and he was
talking about the search at the moment
involving aircraft across uh he said 7
600 7 600 square miles uh and no results
uh yielded yet he said he said a
submersible is on site but with limited
capability and added that Coast Guard
ships should arrive in the coming hours
and then the important fact uh that he
said was that they think there are 40
about 40 hours of breathable air remain
remaining
so correspondent John Sparks is uh in St
John's in Newfoundland and John well
um some detail of the rescue but no good
news at the moment
hi Mark yeah that is that's right I mean
I think the key point there and you've
mentioned it is that their search
efforts have wielded no results so far
and over the last couple of days they
have been able to search a large amount
of territory 7 600 square miles an area
larger than the state of Connecticut
said Captain Fredericks he also went on
to say that this is a really complicated
multi-agency
search and rescue operation
deploying specialist equipment Canadians
the Americans Coast Guard the military
private actors as well we know that
there is a private ship sophisticated
ship on site now that lays cables on the
ocean floor it has sophisticated Imaging
for the bottom of the ocean in place now
but interestingly the U.S Coast Guard
officials saying no one actor has all of
the equipment all of the specialist
equipment and knowledge and techniques
that they need in its entirety to carry
out this search and rescue effort as
such it makes it very complex they've
got to coordinate things amongst the
whole range of actors interesting as
well that he said they're going to move
this operation to St John's in
Newfoundland that's about 380 400 miles
from the wreck of at the Titanic we've
just been speaking to the premier of
Newfoundland so the guy in charge
politically in this province he says
he's been speaking to the Americans he's
been speaking to the British as well
he's offered the assets hard assets and
soft assets everything they've got he'll
do what he can here to help the search
and rescue effort as well but so far no
results I think it it goes to show just
how difficult this task is
okay uh John thank you very much indeed
well uh the Royal Navy Warfare officer
rear Admiral Chris Parry is uh with me
and well just first of all what did you
make of what you heard in that news
conference Mark that was no news uh
they're just saying they're on the case
they don't know where to find this thing
they're looking almost everywhere they
can I think 7 600 miles is a bit steep
if you even plot on where the thing
could have gone if it just drifted it's
not out that far so that they're
actually doing what they can they're
being seen to do what they can so they
don't have a location to start the
search so that's a bit of a problem
there's these remote operated vehicles
that are on site now that can probably
go down and use video cameras but that's
a painstaking search so if you don't
know where to start that's going to be a
long operation and secondly I think
implicitly they said you know what we
don't have a solution even if we do find
it we've got these experts coming
together we've got this Machinery coming
together but I'm not seeing anybody
coming up with a saloon as to how
they're going to bring this thing to the
surface again well it's interesting you
say that because he said there is no one
agency and there are a lot of agencies
involved in this military coast guard
and civilian no one agency has the
equipment yeah you know to to carry out
the rescue even if they identify where
the submersible is yeah I mean what's
going on here is if you've seen the film
Apollo 13 people are scratching their
heads saying well if we find it how are
we going to deal with this because
nobody's attempted this before so I take
the point but right now they don't have
a location they don't have a solution
and the time is running out this is
getting very urgent in terms of air and
unless they bring in some very radical
Solutions which possibly involve active
sauna boys and things like that then
this is this is going to run out of time
and what's your hunch is it still down
there or could it be on the surface
floating around somewhere I think if
it's been floating around somewhere on
the surface it would have been and the
sort of Senses they've got in the
aircraft and the ships are good enough
to find something of this size
I suspect it's still down there and what
condition it's in nobody knows I'm
afraid we just don't have any hard
evidence My worry is it's not
transmitting anything
um so you're not picking up any sonar
pulse or any distressed Beacon so how on
Earth are you going to find this
yeah and
um what sort of rescue operation what
sort of equipment would be needed to
um Carry Out the rescue uh in conceptual
terms the only thing I can only two
things I can think of are getting a wire
down there from the cable ship and
dragging it up or getting another uh
underwater vehicle that's got a grab arm
that can actually grab hold of the thing
and bring it up hug it if you like and
bring it up to the surface that's never
been done over at this depth before it
would be totally new and I'm not sure I
can think of what sort of equipment
would be involved there maybe something
from the oil and gas sector but actually
the depth involved is astonishing so I'm
very worried about this I would be if I
were out there doing this operation
myself because actually I don't have any
ideas
what about the submersibles he mentioned
that were on site and then he said but
with limited capabilities so what would
they be able to do essentially they they
will go down either tethered or they'll
go untethered in other words
semi-autonomous and I think what he was
hinting at is they've got sort of
Imaging uh cameras on the front and
they'll go and look but that's like
plowing a field you don't have any wide
vision so you can't cover a huge area
they're going to have to go up and down
up and down until they find something
let's not forget the amount of debris
that's in this area around the Titanic
so it's going to be a very difficult
task if they pull this off it will be
stunning there's no question about that
yeah and I mean if if they are still
alive down there
um as you say time is running out he
mentioned this figure of 40 hours of
breathable air remaining and I would
think that that's probably at best
that's assuming there's been no other
sort of yeah problems yeah they may have
run out of electricity by now of course
it may be getting cold down there
there's all sorts of problems one
doesn't like to think of the worst case
scenario but the odds are stacked
there's no question about it in your
experience is anything like this before
um well obviously I mean look there was
the submarine the curse yeah
um but which was a completely different
situation in terms of it was Russian
military on the submarine and they
couldn't be rescued well with the curse
they could have been rescued because a
rescue vehicle particularly a British
one that can actually get in position
over the escape hatch of the curse could
have got people out because you can
transfer directly from the submarine to
the Escape module that they weren't
asked but no I'm afraid they were asked
the Russian I think it just come into
power and I yeah they just just kept
hold of it they refused to release any
information and I think 23 Sailors who
are alive in that submarine died as a
result
um not the case here you can't put a
capsule like this over the top of this
sort of submersible you also can't get
them down to that depth to do it so the
thing's got to come off the bottom if
you find it one way or another either
through a submersible grabbing it and
bringing it to the surface or through a
cable bringing it up but I must stress
the key issue is finding it and frankly
that press conference they're just
saying look we're doing all we can but
you know not so much effect at the
moment so just to sum up you think
things are pretty bleak
I think uh I think I would reflect on
the fact that I'm an optimist who
worries a lot I'm worrying a lot about
this
okay uh Chris for now thank you very
much indeed let's bring in retired
submarine commander in the U.S Navy
Captain David Marquez thank you very
much indeed for being with us and I
don't know whether you heard what was
said in the news conference but it does
seem that they're they're mounting a a
major search operation but at the moment
there is no good news
okay
yeah I agree with that and I and I
listened to the ADM I and I agree with
what he's saying his assessment of it uh
what I found concerning was first of all
they didn't they haven't found it yet so
it's probably on the bottom it's not on
the surface now we're using these rovs
and so so imagine they're going like
inch by inch they're searching inch by
inch by inch and we have a big area on
the bottom that the thing could be so
it's like I'm surfing a football pitch
with a magnifying glass we could get
lucky we could find it but uh we don't
like the bank on luck uh the thing I
found concerning was the way the
commander was talking about hey look
what we were just focusing on finding it
and we always would try and think in
terms of parallel action so the next
step is once we find it we got to get it
up to the surface these guys are bolted
in from the outside so we got to get up
to the surface and over to the
Mothership so we can unbolt it and then
free them and so they can breathe oxygen
again so what you need to be doing is
getting whatever ship has the ability to
drop that cable and then connect it to
the this lost submarine and bring it
back up you need to be doing that now so
that when you find it you're not
starting fresh oh hey look let's look
around see if we can find a ship that's
got a cable so to me I'm a little
concerned which it sort of almost sounds
to me like
they've kind of admitted that the
chances are really really really Slim on
this so slim is probably not even worth
moving to the next step it did seem that
way and they did mention these
submersibles at the scene now
um but they didn't go into great detail
they didn't seem to think that they
could be of much use they said limited
capability
well yeah so these are submersibles are
designed for a different function uh
it's either a oil
industry ship or a cabling ship so
they're designed to go to a specific
spot that they know they know where
they're going they look at something
they maybe can manipulate the cable or
something on the bottom and then they
come back up and what we're trying to
use them for is a what we would call
wide area surge and something like
scanning with your eyes on the surface
or scanning with a radar or scanning
with a sonar system that's designed for
those wide area searches that's what you
need but they're doing the best with the
tool that they have in in the terms of
using this submersible to try and find
the submarine
so it is
um a Race Against Time he did mention
this figure of about 40 hours of
breathable air
um so that just gives a a sense of what
a Race Against Time it is and presumably
uh there's the question of the weather
as well
yeah well every of course if the weather
turns bad that just makes everything uh
10 10 times harder and if they're alive
on the submarine they're doing
everything they can to extend that that
oxygen supply their
meditating they're napping they're not
doing any excess movements I probably
have someone banging on the Hole uh say
rhythmically every 15 minutes and see if
that sound could transmit you want to be
doing the following three things number
one
if you're on the bottom
figure out what's broken so you can get
to the surface number two if you can't
do that or in addition make noise use
your transmitters pingers if those
aren't working bang on the hall and then
number three extending your oxygen you
do that by remaining calm reducing your
metabolic activity
meditating and uh and that will reduce
the amount of oxygen you use and the
amount of carbon dioxide poison that you
put into this very small confined space
that's shared by five people should we
take some Hope from the fact that
certainly
um there are experienced explorers down
there um there is an experienced
submersible pilot down there
um the Frenchman who it seems has been
down many times should we take some Hope
from that they will be going through
what you have just said maybe
yeah these are not naive people even the
people described as quote tourists
um like Hamish Harding they're not naive
they are the right people to do the
right things in the situation but human
willpower is only so much
the laws of physics the fact that this
is 300 times atmospheric pressure
pressing on on on the ship
it's that's going to be really hard to
overcome and just finally uh Captain I
just wondered what your view is of you
know a commercial operation like this uh
in a submersible like this at a depth
like this
as a member of the human race I
appreciate the fact that there are
explorers that go and climb mountains
and try to find the Straits of Magellan
and
press into space and the deepest parts
of the ocean we're we're better off as a
as a species because of uh these people
but not all these people come back and
it's it's risky I'm I think these people
knew the risk
when they signed up the CEO of the
company is on board so he certainly
believed in his equipment but I know how
hard it is to keep a submarine at Sea in
the corrosive old terrible environment
with the pressure pressing in fittings
corrode then they leak and then the
water causes rust and it makes a pipe
thin and then that pipe burst and next
thing you know you have a major accident
so it's really daunting to think about
what
behind that the Royal Navy the US Navy
Australian Navy we have the resources to
have the people and the testing and
inspections that we do all the time on
our vessels and I I just don't know
whether commercial entity
is dedicating those resources those kind
of resources because they're trying to
make a profit okay Captain look I really
appreciate your expertise and your time
thank you very much indeed
cheers and just to recap what we heard
in that news conference at this major
search operation is underway in the
Atlantic but uh the U.S Coast Guard
Captain Jamie Frederick saying as yet no
uh results have been yielded and uh it's
hoped that Coast Guard ships will be on
the scene